hey guy that's kind of an EQ sort of
circle right now we don't have a whole
set and we have a pod cut out okay so
this is question 8 is question 8 you can
hold on to
hmm actually let me let me draw the
measurements on if they don't give me my
keys now like I said they've got a pot
cut out of it so let me just cut that
out now I didn't bring this on with me I
gave back to chance there you go okay
now they give you two measurements the
first one is this sub this angle in here
again it's 40 degrees I just know close
to 40 degrees but anyway and then what's
the other measurement they give you it
has a name what's it called
the distance is 184 meters but what does
that like what's that
related to this circle like it has it
has a name start to be it's the diode
that's right so um okay now it's
important to get that it's the diameter
because when we're working out the area
of this in a second we don't want the
diameter we want something else okay so
a couple of things the first thing is
this is 40 degrees but that's the part
we don't want we work with on this part
that's the part we actually want right
so how do I work out the size of this
angle yeah okay I will find out the
radius actually why don't we find out
the radius now half the diameter is
thing we said 62 meters
wasn't it so I'm going to put that there
because you know that's that's one of
the that's the radius okay Luke
the angle yeah okay perfect now 306
degrees minus 4 degrees why where does
this 360 come from it's correct but
what's C Y of 361 or 370 or 380 this is
a fool revolution right that's all the
way around okay so you've got that and
you're taking away so of course thank
yous units of 320 ok so there you go
that's the angle okay super already who
helped us work out what the radius is
okay so now what we want to work out the
area okay it's not a wholesome lot a
whole circle how much of the circle is
it what's most of it is it up but to be
more specific it's this much of the same
thing you see what's going on here right
if for instance we had half the circle
we had a semi semi okay let me just
quickly draw one of those for you I'm
thinking out a semi circle because you
guys know semi circles a little bit up
okay now a semi circle is half the
circle right so let's just take the same
dimension to you let's say the radius
was 62 okay now if this is half a circle
what's the angle it's 180 degrees you
can also see you know it's a straight
line 180 degrees is the aim of some of
the straight line okay
so if I work out the area of this thing
it's 1/2 times whatever the area of a
circle is PI R squared okay
but this half here is really a hundred
and eighty over 360 you see it's this
angle right that tells you how much of
the circle you've gone if I have a
hundred a leotard a circle if I had only
19 how much of the circle would that be
corner in fact we call that a quadrant
right now this love is really awkward
320 it's not a special number but it
tells us how much of this circle we want
okay so this fine to y'all
very few people go on so that's much
meeting point you write this one down
okay now that's how much this sucker you
want what's the whole circle apply swear
and we already went down with the radius
was right so 320 on 360 and from here
pretty much a calculator can take over
okay if you put it incorrectly obviously
you can simplify this fraction a little
bit if you want it to I think it's um
what is it seven eighths
eight ninths eight ninths but all the
same the cafe they don't give you this
and that's to two decimal places
okay so there's a lot to that though
there's a lot to it there's a lot of
work in that question which is why it
was worth so many marks so let me just
rehearse where they are one mark for
getting that angle that's tricky one
mark for getting this radius and
realizing that you need the radius and
you can't just work with anybody for I
think the other mark was here for noting
how you gonna use that angle that 320
right you're going to use it by doing
this kind of division okay okay any
questions on that
they wanna clarify any beads
if you did it nicely like that except
you didn't so I think you missed this
part okay that sounds like you get two
out of four the reason why I'll tell you
what because if that means the angle was
calculated then that's one like there
and if it means that you did use the
angle then that's another like pencil
mark as well okay um what we call that
is a simplified carried for whatever so
there's different kinds of areas that
you quit I'll give an example suppose I
calculate this role suppose I said it
was 300 degrees okay so you will not get
that mark because you are the angle
right but getting that angle wrong
doesn't make this any easier like you
start to do all the same out look you're
just gonna slide into a number at the
end so she ate everything exactly the
same you've got 300 degrees got some
other number out here nine thousand in
something okay um you get three knocks
you lose one month from making one arrow
okay on the other hand what you just
described
not having the angle at all right that
actually substantially makes the
question easier like that's easy to work
out then when you've got that angle
thing on the front okay so that's why
you're not eligible for three months
you're in the year to go to 360 oh you
mean like you mean like hugs it's 360 or
316 like completely ignore the 42 oh
yeah well that's not I mean if you're
ignoring it that makes the question much
easier it simplifies it so there's less
complexity in the question so it'll be
just like in fact is exactly like you
know in them in any Olympic sport
where there is you know like say figure
skating diving synchronized to me was
kind of things with the difficulty of
your routine affects the maximum score
you can get right obviously if if my
routine is just like dive into the pool
and not do any spinning or
or you know some sorting whatever right
prevailing perfectly surely I can't get
the same mark as someone who you know
does all these twists and turns and all
this complicated stuff okay
you know actually I probably couldn't
because anyway but they go okay so by
simplifying the question you lose out on
all the marks that you would have gone
that everyone else if they have done the
full question would have received good
question